welcome back scram I mean justin hays
and today we are all singing all
sparkling new zorroski concepts over
here in the heart of London we're gonna
bring you the best VIPs we're gonna be
talking about sparkles accessories and
everything else your topic I know has
some nice necklace there's my name and
then an earring as well I mean I feel
like a bag of money I'm not gonna die
gay men like Goodson she's dripping
she's Berkeley don't get yourself
walking up this bar plow there's me at
my spot this girl is bad she's busy
she's sparkling what do you think makes
this part of the maze
[Applause]
all I need is to go and find them tucked
up in bed have a little sleep and I'm
like that's it going to adopt me you are
the ultimate motivator okay there's a
quote that I've got written on my toilet
low like that and it says worry is a
total waste of time
all it does is steal your joy that keep
me very busy doing absolutely nothing
it's about being a bit more present
right a hundred percent
thank your feet deep in Sasuke when I
bake too much I take the cake round to
my neighbours and then stop because I
keep ending up
what is your top tip the party season
this year would you say I love sequin I
love still I love Bell dings and I'm
playing and that makes you feel sexy
dress to flatter your board a yeah
unless you want to go oversized
everyone's kind of flattering on area
besides the holidays but I also quite
like it so you give a little bit of like
bit show in the middle baby is a midriff
yes
key and guessing that's the top tip the
party season got a secret until one day
that's when you get all the office
Christmas party they get every year
[Music]